um
uh i want to continue the discussion
about uh freenomics and language
learning on the internet and and the
link the link model
uh
i mentioned that uh we feel that a lot
of the cost that
traditionally has gone into language
courses or buying lots of books and cds
has
or can be replaced by a different model
which uses the internet which uses handy
little ipods that we can have with us
all the time
we feel that link
is a very good way to go about learning
languages
i mentioned that the freenomics model is
one whereby
a small number of elite users in fact
pay for a large number of free users but
there's more to it and i want to talk
about another piece uh in in that
picture and that is the role of podcasts
there has been an explosion
in podcasting uh i think thousands tens
of tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of people use podcasts for
language learning
uh it may very well be that many of you
who are listening to me right now
are people who are learning english as a
second language and who use this podcast
as
content that for whatever reason
you find worthwhile listening to and
that by listening to it you are
improving your english
at link we have started producing
podcasts in different languages we have
had our
english link podcast for quite a while
english link
dot com
but we have now started with some months
ago we started french link spanish link
russian link japanese links
chinese link german link portuguese link
italian link
and the idea there is that
we put these out
people are interested in learning those
languages swedish link as well
they download them
they can then come to link where we have
a transcript
and by using the transcript and by using
links functionality they can put these
podcasts
to good use
our model is somewhat different from
some of the other language podcasts
which are more
along the lines of a traditional lesson
typically the podcast most language
podcasters will provide the podcast free
of charge and then they will charge for
a worksheet for a lesson for
explanations or possibly for the
transcript
our model is different we have some
beginner podcasts
and we mix in with those
what i would call authentic
everyday native speakers speaking to
each other type of podcasts
what i want to explore at link is the
extent to which
a language learner can start learning
the language with real language rather
than beginner language we offer the
beginner language i think most learners
seem to prefer the beginner language but
i think that it is quite possible to use
uh small doses of authentic language and
link
and listen over and over again to this
content and really improve in the
language quite quickly
so we are looking for people to help us
because while i have uh done some
podcasts in japanese and french and
spanish and german and swedish
it's for even chinese it's preferable
that these podcasts be
uh conversations occasionally the odd
monologue but it should involve native
speakers so we have put the word out and
i by this very podcast and and youtube i
want to put the word out
people out there
why not join our community that link
uh
give us a podcast
five minutes ten minutes
10 minutes preferable i think that's a
good length
talk to your husband wife friend
mother
child
talk about what you do whether you live
in
in buenos aires or
you know
athens or singapore
it doesn't matter people are interested
in hearing about other people in the
world
now this has started we've received some
very interesting spanish language
podcasts from people night clubbing in
buenos aires or a
mexican and chilean couple talking about
the different foods that they like to
cook
and
we would like people
to help us with podcasts and we are
prepared
to give points because some of you may
know that at link a lot of the functions
are free however in order to access our
tutors or to have writing corrected you
need points but we are willing to pay
points we're willing to pay a thousand
points for a ten minute podcast
so
right now we're going to limit it to the
languages that are available at link
which is of course english french
spanish german
russian
portuguese italian
chinese japanese i don't think i left
anything out
if you are a native speaker of any of
those languages
if you have
an interest
people seem to either use audacity
a-u-d-a-c-i-t-y
as a recording software or with the mac
wiretap studios is a very good piece of
software audacity happens to be free
and they produce these mp3 files
i think generally speaking a usb
microphone gives better sound quality
uh
often the sound quality will also depend
on the sound card in your in your
computer we're quite happy to provide
technical advice for people
but we would really like to collect it's
almost like a wiki
uh we would like to collect the voices
of people
uh wherever they are
talking about their lives or local
events or things of interest or what
makes their particular region
attractive or or what are special
features or customs or
uh
seasons of the year or whatever it might
be ten minutes long conversations are
preferred and we don't mind if you s
whatever regional variant or accent you
have in your language
we're very interested in in receiving
podcasts as i say we will compensate
people with points
for the podcast that we use
you don't have to worry about
transcribing them because we will
transcribe them
so we look forward to hearing from
people who would like to
join our
link series of
podcasts uh please let me know if you're
interested you can contact us
at
customer service at link lingq.com
uh i look forward to hearing from you
thank you